that's one two one two hey guys this is
John welcome back to middle ground we
just wanted to remind you that we have a
podcast and the podcast is called
radical empathy it's all about having
empathy for perspectives that are far
outside your own and kind of challenging
yourself to see or at least consider
other people's views we would like to
thank a few people for helping us put
together this episode of middle ground
Lawrence Cartwright boogaloo who's in
the video as well as Malik Spellman
helped us cast this episode we want to
keep exploring communities and
perspectives and cultures that you don't
normally see in mainstream media and we
want to bring those authentic
discussions to you so let us know in the
comments what you want us to explore
enjoy the episode I still think I'm
again almost guaranteed that i'ma die
from free violence are you okay with
that
Willis have you accepted that as a man
yes I wanted my message to impact gang
culture you know I'm one of you wherever
I end up you're gonna you're gonna know
that you can end up - you're - I was
affiliated with the blood gang for my
entire life
my heart my soul my family our blood
I'm affinity captain in the park Pyro's
diantha's pardon Miller gangster blood
probably black p stone jungle I'm
affiliated with the rolling 16
gangbanging foot most of my life no high
school diploma but I feel like I know it
all though when you young you know that
excitement of it the Brotherhood you
kind of like fall victim to it but I
feel like it also prepares you for the
real world and get you ready for like a
lot of like obstacles that you might run
across everybody just labels a gaming R
as just a terrorist threat you know just
not real human beings but that's not the
fact
[Music]
Hey yo what's going on my name's Eddie
Mack I'm from at this part I do rap in
comedy and I'm said jack-of-all-trades
ready
my name is a nasty I'm from captain
spook town freshly paroled from prison a
certified welder
my name's wobbler I'm from the jungles
from becoming artists in Los Angeles
California
my name is Kip Townsend and I come up to
West Adams area and I'm a job developer
and also do human development as well
yeah I'm Boogaloo Westside Nellas I
wanted to ceo's Rosecrans entertainment
Monday and why I saw a cab another part
I'm up-and-coming artist came from you
I'll do a little bit everything just try
to play my part and then 84 old 60s and
I'm a street activist let's talk about
this stuff a lot of people like in gangs
you know we grew up together that's like
brothers
I can go spend a night at my homies
house you feel like mama feed me you
further saying that together we didn't
came up with ways that we could uh feed
the children we didn't the backpack
giveaway he's been dead all type of [ __ ]
but the media they always put out the
negative about us but they never like
put out the positive [ __ ] that we didn't
do it I feel like the media got like an
old-school perception on what gang
banging is or what gang banging is about
a modern-day gang banging has evolved
from what it's being back then so now
it's okay for Bloods and Crips to go to
school together that's where back in the
days you couldn't find a [ __ ] at
Centennial you probably couldn't find a
blur at crash or like y'all said so
nowadays we can't coexist they don't
never really show the unity of it or
like they they always show the
separation the segregation they don't
really fathom the strength and the power
we got inside
community and I really don't think they
really care about that they put us in
this one statistic box you know and they
leave us right there that's what I wrote
this book it's really up to us to say
okay at least the nation at least the
next generation you're gonna come with
something you're gonna come with
positivity we live in but we really not
sorry that we too in competition with
each other everybody hard no no you know
so I see everything on social media and
everything I'm really locked in with all
I mean I posted something positive about
me giving backpacks away and stuff out
the parking all that with the homies and
stuff it didn't it kinda like what a
thousand views mm I get like $5.00
viewers not posting some crazy though
you get me when you do a positive you
cloud chasing are you doing negative
it's all good cuz that's what we used to
that's the bread and butter I guess
that's what we already do so what's
happening right now is you bout to leave
a legacy right but it's not gonna be a
financial legacy see if there was
something he was doing positive and all
in 5,000 views you got they gonna do
endo down about to 300 if he was
empowering the community and shedding
light and like you saying waking people
up then all that's gonna go away but as
long as you've got the negative
influence yeah well you gonna leave that
legacy but ain't nobody gonna be able to
eat afterwards the first time ever seen
somebody close to me pastor I was I was
young older cousin fighting for my mama
house another and another black man is
this typical success again man and it's
like visualizing that as a young as a
young boy is like that's probably one of
the reasons why I am Who I am today is
traumatizing and it instantly adapts you
to your community to your environment to
where you went because it's like if you
don't get in like this you're gonna get
down like this I was 19 years old man
and I have seen a lot of people get shot
but I was sitting there talking to this
dude it was actually kid Kevin Sykes
from 60s we sitting there talking for
about an hour I'm waiting to go skating
and as soon as he crossed the street the
van pulled up they have been waiting the
whole time and they gunned him and
that's really [ __ ] me up man to see
that
could easily just came up and gun does
both it wasn't about creeper blood it
was just about that anger and rage like
man want to hurt somebody and man it
left something avoiding me that was like
spiritual like man what is God doing but
also that rage was like man I want to
hurt somebody and and I took him with me
from the age of 19 and I just felt
suicidal like I signed up every day to
go out and be dead I didn't care I'm
gonna hurt somebody they gonna hurt me
to this day I still think I'm Garen
almost guaranteed that i'ma die from
street violence are you okay with that
Willis have you accepted that as a man
yes I said you because it's like all the
negativity I didn't dist out see I want
to kind of get because this is what's
causing me to to change because I made
that same pact that same vile for my
game I'm gonna die for my game I do life
for this [ __ ] yeah but recent [ __ ] I
showed me that nah I got another purpose
I could do something else I don't have
to die it's a game banging let me let me
ask you something real quick though you
got a child a baby a girl I got four
beautiful blessings yeah whoa beautiful
bless so here's the thing would you die
for them of course but that's not what
they want
yes they they need you to live for me
and you ready to go out everyday and die
for them and then the same people need
you to be alive and well I didn't lost
singing homies I lost some [ __ ] me I
lost some good homes I'm over with this
gang banging [ __ ] if something happened
to y'all y'all will see that I'm so
serious about this [ __ ] but I'm on a
whole nother note home respect me from
and I don't one of those job if
[ __ ] don't wake up and let me
save each other so it don't have to be
no more losses we don't lose
straight up
I do I already do
that's gonna be hard right I'm actually
did it that's why I feel like it could
be peace because I've actually set in a
circle and had a conversation with my
enemies we cleared the air and then
killed out a little difference now it's
not peace between all my enemies but
it's peace with the main enemy yeah with
us and we not even gonna call it peace
we will call it understanding because
that's what it was understanding was
y'all stay on your side we stay on our
side don't disrespect that line then we
good and keep our like Internet goofy
[ __ ] you know listen I'll keep that [ __ ]
out of the circle and we good and it's
been working so far we had a little
bumps and bruises this this question was
complex to me because I'm thinking like
are we talking about individually or
gang-wise I'll be talking about in
today's world aren't I are we working
towards the future to get better because
I believe that in the future sooner or
later we are gonna be able to function
right now with things that's been going
on and the politics it's more to see
with the 8th race and the six holes that
was an eye-opener for LA because it was
like if that's what modern day gang
banging is working towards right now
it'd just take time people nowadays like
it's a revenge cycle it's people that's
gonna kill you that don't gangbang they
a family or friend or somebody John my
brother you feel me
sometimes the peas don't even be like on
us cuz we're not big nobody bigger than
the court you know so it's like alright
how is that how is that one person right
there just gonna say it's peace today
and then everything else is just peaches
and cream I look at it like peace today
is our just for the simple cause of
matter like it hasn't been a long period
of time without a death or without a
retaliation or without another man woman
from from from from from a rival rival
gang getting murdered show that show
wanna come to my hood and bust on me at
knocking me down let me show you the
same thing and then once we get that
understood then you can go about to let
me go by my my minutes but it's a thing
called leaders and followers if some
leaders that's gonna be speaking piece
you're gonna have some leaders like no
they didn't they're too much it's this
history this is what it is
it's like as much as you want peace I
just live life for my individual peace I
believe at the very bottom of joining
the game it's ultimately a choice the
power of influence is is crazy and it
will blind you to make you think that
it's not a lot of people is
family-orientated are born into it but
at the end of the day I have the choice
to say yes this is what I want to do no
they're saying what I want to do no
matter what age I am or not
I feel like it's for sure a choice it's
not like how it used to be we're like
you said you feel me you you you got
some type of ties to this game nowadays
it's like oh I love make a little turn
hey you you hang with a [ __ ] for a cool
amount of time build a relationship with
them if you really a [ __ ] and you feel
me you really got stripes in rep like
you do from your air you can easily take
them over there and make it happen it's
a choice to certain people certain
people just got it go with the flow this
it's not so much of a choice it's like
it's like a way of life where I come
from in my family because we always
gangbang I grew up to to seeing blue
rags I grill just saying my brother's
gonna fight the enemies at parks I grew
up to saying dope sacks I grew up with
my daddy whippin dope and kitchens and
all that so it's like that's not a
choice it's just that to it you go dad
this [ __ ] chose me I signed up and they
accept it you feel me this [ __ ] like the
military listen I play I mean you know
my daddy from company you know from the
kid this [ __ ] had me in his red
Cadillac slapping through Compton rollin
up eating any dope my mama
side of the family my cousin from Palmer
block [ __ ] then I got other cousins from
neighborhood Piru down the street and
then I moved to the 60s at eight years
old then my older cousins they started
gangbanging you from you so it was just
a way of life for me that's what my
family was about it wasn't no choice I'm
luckily I had big homies to where they
they didn't want me to gangbang you
feelin I said they always told me played
football
I had homies that didn't want me to
vaneeta you for me that was like 80 go
play basketball go play football
I even had a [ __ ] that peanut he used
to come to me and say it's done game
baby and I used to think this [ __ ]
thought I was soft yeah but the whole
time my [ __ ] was being a real man and
didn't wanted me to do this [ __ ] you
feel me I want to be Bruce Lee man Bruce
Lee yeah I want to come home and kick
everybody man
but the Crips was at the movie theater
so we had to fight the crisp and I'm
nine years old and I'm like man I want
to go to the movies so it wasn't a
choice it was like man am I at the age
of 13 I'm like you know what I'm gonna
stop being a victim i'ma fight back
police because they the biggest gang in
America they basically got alright to
knock us down
ya know with no justice after that yeah
and on the side of them cop course it
says to protect the serve but they ain't
doing it they taking us so it's like of
course I'm a fear you because you don't
want that supposed to protect this so
I'm looking at you in the sense of okay
you posed to be safety but no you really
coming at me to a gun now you feel me
but I but I'm looking at this may not
know how he coming it isn't it's not a
facade how you gonna come so I prepared
for how you gonna come you feel me
so when a cop come at you why all the
time if I'm posed to be protected assert
why I gotta put my hands up all the time
just keep the simple man I'm afraid the
police because this safer this is my
enemy shooting me and I survived
I can go revenge and honor that you
further say the police to me I survive
and he can smoke me and can get away
with it my homies they go and go rally
up and go smoke them because I know
where to go they just sent him to Santa
Barbara somewhere he throwing up saying
he had a whole other department
no no I don't know not at all
the reason why I wouldn't want my sons
or my daughter to be in a gang is
because of the way the perception that
society has on a gang it's not about the
way the community views a gang because
all that is the address but if my child
is from a gang then I don't fear the
communities around it I fear the police
I fear that if if my son breaking a
house well he should go to jail for a
year or two but if he ain't a gang he
gonna get a 12-year enhancement I don't
want my daughter to be in the game
because reality there's only two roads
to the city either death or jail it's
only food I slipped through the cracks
it's like I just want my kids again me
because I know how hard game banging
limits you definitely you know it keeps
you stagnated you know you can't you
can't you can't go out there and be
adventurous and see the world and like
for my son my son he can grow up in and
love a woman and her brothers could be
from from a gang that now you can't even
you can't even love for you really want
to love because you know just don't
don't limit yourself I don't want my
kids to limit themselves this generation
and gang banging is a gift and a curse
because it's kind of beautiful because
we come from a generation that we
figuring it out we breaking it out we
got a lot of black entrepreneurs we got
sports players we got rappers we got
people that got their own clothing lines
and this is all people that came from a
gang so it's like we're not all bad just
cuz we came from a game but as far as my
kids getting involved with that you
don't have to gangbang and do all this
stuff because you could go way further
doing it if we're outdoors getting tired
but also gang culture influences every
Tupac got influenced by gang cultures
and cost them is life so it's like it's
like gang culture influences everybody
but for my kids my niece is my nephews
and everybody under me I do not want
that for
because it took so much of my life I
mean personally I don't have any kids
but this topic right here I got a little
twist to it it's the definition of the
word because see it's being black the
definition of a gang is oh they heard
looks they thirst but if you from a
white gang oh that's a collective
community they just they're just some
regular people that do the same thing at
the same time everyday so you know what
I just might want my kids to be in a
gang a damn good one but like our LAPD
or our Sheriff some [ __ ] for us you feel
me so yeah I will yeah I want my kid to
be in a gang a positive one number
I feel like that coming is probably very
kind of like valid in the sense cuz
everybody would question and like what
type of gang members will want to speak
openly about games on TV but that's what
separates the leaders from the followers
of the game so it's all it's all a
mindset it's really a mindset I'm
talking about getting over beef in which
other enemies and everything it starts
with our mind said first hopefully I can
shine enough light so other everybody
see what else everybody else see what
I'm doing and be like all right he came
from that he did this and he doing this
and now look at him yeah he's still back
in this hood which I really commend
nipsey for everything he did because he
showed us that at the end of the day
Nipsey Hussle got so big and he died
from gang bang and politics he died
being a 60 crib that the world couldn't
even believe it so they said it was a
conspiracy but I have the heart of it he
lived his life as a real gangbanger and
did what he was supposed to do and when
he died he died for standing up for
what's right that every gangbanger
should have felt the same way and it
showed behind the love that he got that
and I feel like I was a gangbanger
that's how you would want your legacy to
be when you when you die it's like I'm
bigger than gangbanging for the people
that judges gangbanging and all that
it's like this like I'm you and you me I
could easily live your life if I was
pretty I placed me right there I'm
living my best life that I was given
I wasn't given a golden spoon I wasn't
given a silver phone oh I got this
little styrofoam plate and it's plastic
spoon and I'm a bill and I'm gonna go
with it so before you get judgmental and
say I'm a gangbanger then they doing it
come see it's all about what she making
I never thought that I would be seen
here with y'all I never thought I'd be
saying with no blood I never thought I'd
be seen with no conklin Crips
I never thought I'd be seeing with
nowhere
the sixties and I didn't want to sit
when over the game when I was a
youngster I didn't want to do nothing
but go hurt people
I didn't want to do number gangbang and
make the hill proud but now that's not
the question
my fight is for these people for them my
fighters for every l8 game that's my
fight
I'm from every LA game now so if anybody
got a problem with that I got a problem
with it pushing this piece
[Applause]
[Music]